bloß verbraucher aus hobby bloß
verbraucher
also diskriminiert sehr gut man war das
bei die anderen 40 leider herrscht sorgt
also durchaus natürlich super aus aber
wenn ich das sagen darf dieses
eierschalen bei steht dir gar nicht
vielleicht solltest du perlweiß
versuchen oder dem rhein weiß ja oder
mittels weiß
auch mit deine blöden witz man warum
sind mama hat dabei die wollten doch das
kleiderkauf war mama ist halt nicht doch
weil mama hat netto ist und darum benito
ist zurück
ja was ist jetzt kommt das nächste
chance hoch melodien der scheidung steht
bist du oder
also sehr gut ja du schaust toll aus
grundsätzlich aber wenn ich das sagen
darf der sirene schnitt ist einfach
nichts für deine figur die konkret über
ihre hochzeit ja auch suchen sie leben
kleid an die kann das aber auch tragen
mit ihrer teile
und die paletten die tragen halt noch
mal extra auf also wenn ich das sagen
darf
unter freunden muss man ja ehrlich sein
vielleicht mag es einfach gleich sagen
dass ich fett bin
ach deswegen serien im schnitt
und was für ihre märchen rumpelstilzchen
so kommt das nächste
das sehr gut
das ist gar nicht so schlecht
ja das ist dann immer dann mache ich die
rechnung fertig bevor sie jemand anders
überlegt
wahnsinn das hätte ich nie geglaubt als
wir letzte woche hier gestanden sind wie
die mama gesagt hat immer sie nur lange
genug nerven und sagte zu allem ja
[Gelächter]